Asalam allayikum.
Today I'm going to be doing a response
to a duplicious man. A man who twists
and skews the facts in order to suit his
own Zionistic agenda.
a man who's too cowardly and spineless
to move forward and debate somebody on
equal footing with him and who just like
his army that he supports the Zionist
Israeli army only likes to pick on kids
and college students. It's none other
than the little man, the puny man,
Ben Shapiro. Let's take a look at what
this man says and come back and respond
to it.
You've been watching the media today,
I'm sure, and you have seen that there
is violence in Jerusalem. Now, the way
the media cover this sort of stuff is
they always suggest that it's a cycle of
violence. Both sides are to blame. This
is because the media are ignorant and
stupid and have no expectations of
humane and decent behavior by radicals
in the Palestinian community. Now, the
vast majority of Palestinians are not
people presumably who want to engage in
violence and terrorism, but there are a
lot of people in that community who do
in fact want to engage in violence and
terrorism. And those people tend to
occupy the highest rungs of Palestinian
governmental structures. Hamas runs at
the Gaza Strip. It is an open terrorist
group. Islamic Jihad and Fatah are the
other groups that run Judea and Samaria,
the so-called West Bank. Hey, those
groups are terrorist groups. They've
been terrorist groups for a very long
time. Now, the pretext for all of this
is the eviction of some Palestinian
families from Shik Jar, from homes in
Shik Jar. Okay? They're allowed to live
elsewhere. They're just not allowed to
live in these particular homes because
they don't have legal deed to these
homes. There's been a string of dis
and put this as a legal issue. East
Jerusalem is not the property and is not
recognized as Israel by the entire
international community, including the
UN, WHICH GAVE YOUR PATHETIC STATE its
legitimacy in the first instance.
How dare you come and and and trivialize
the plight? HOW DARE YOU trivialize the
plight of those evicted for no good
reason at all from a territory that
doesn't even belong to your state that
you protect the state of Israel.
Decisions going all the way back to 1970
by Israeli courts suggesting that people
who have the original legal deeds to
these homes have the Israeli courts
don't have a jurisdiction in East
Jerusalem. Mentioning Israeli courts in
the context of East Jerusalem means that
you are complicit and you are
acquiescent.
Not even you are supportive of a
colonial occupier
which is Israel. It's an occupier of
East Jerusalem.
It's it suits you well to ignore
international law and to ignore the UN
when it suits you
when it's the very UN that gave you the
LEGITIMACY THAT YOU THINK you have as a
state, the so-called state of Israel.
How dare you try and trivialize the
plight of those people?
Ability to charge rent to the people
living in homes. people haven't been
paying the rent and so now they're going
to be taken out of the homes the same
way that if you don't pay your rent in
the United
you're going to be taken out of the
homes you're going to be taken out of
the homes who the hell do you think you
are to tell people you're going to be
taken out of their homes I want to show
the people today I want to show them a
clip of what he's talking about and this
man
and I use this term loosely because he
is fidgeting
and moving around in his He is wriggling
like a worm on the hook,
perpetuating a monstrous falsehood. HE'S
INTOXICATED WITH FALSE opinion
and bias.
I want to show you what he's talking
about because the question is 25 days
before Hamas even threw a rocket, before
Hamas even
decided to do anything offensively, it
was the Israeli forces which went into
Masa
and delivered people out
of that masid IN THE MOST HOLY time with
no provocation at all. The question is
what was Hamas doing to instigate this?
Hamas didn't do anything to instigate
this.
I want to show you a video which I saw
and you must watch the whole thing. It's
from Vice News. A video that I saw which
will capture for you what indeed took
place.
It could potentially be very dangerous
to the people that are here.
[music]
It's nighttime prayers for Palestinian
Muslims. And this year, Israeli forces
showed up unannounced.
Look what you're doing. Look what you're
doing. Where is Hamas?
You triggered the protests and that's
what triggered the anger today.
Palestinians feel like they're being
pushed out of East Jerusalem. The city
they see is the capital of a future
Palestinian state. They say Israel is
upping its efforts to redraw the borders
of the city. But Israel claims it
belongs to them despite the United
Nations saying it's an occupation.
Exactly. The United Nations says it's an
occupation.
The Israeli police have been arrested.
Look at that. Even the journalist, she's
under she's under attack. Look at that.
Look at that. Look what they're doing.
Look what they're doing. Brutalizing
them.
Taken away by police.
Look at a look at
Yeah. True. YES.
IT'S TRUE.
Why they taking a bloody kid teenager?
Now the question the question is here at
this point where is Hamas did nothing at
this point. You can't put scapegoat
everything on Hamas. This was 25 days
before Hamas threw a rocket. Don't say
Hamas and use that as your ultimate
scapegoat for everything that's happened
because we know that even before Hamas
existed in 1987 the same stuff was
happening. Don't scapegoat it on Hamas.
Before Hamas existed and it was the PLO
Arafat and those individuals, you are
doing the same things. Whoever it will
be, ANY RESISTANCE AGAINST YOUR STATE,
YOUR CORRUPT STATE, you're going to call
terrorism. Anything. And yes, WE CONDEMN
WHAT Hamas does by killing civilians and
so on. We don't agree with their
strategies, but we don't accept you
scapegoating them and trying to divert
the narrative to Hamas.
THIS IS BEFORE Hamas done anything. SO
DON'T EVER COME AND SAY it's Hamas.
THESE ARE PEOPLE PRAYING. The woman is
there. You can watch the whole 20-minut
segment. DON'T YOU DARE COME AND say
Hamas. How dare you. How dare you not
condemn the Israeli army and the
authorities for these kind of things.
How dare you? And you want us to believe
that this is because of Hamas and
because of terrorism?
As Ramadan continued, Palestinians in
East Jerusalem faced stung grenades,
arrests, and water cannons. Some of the
worst violence seen in years. How long
exactly have you lived in this house
to come out of this house?
Absolutely.
Are King a right-wing activist who was a
look at this look at this racist this
guy this area king by the way on the
record and he's going to be you're going
to see it. You're going to see this
animal. No matter how much anyone wants
to be an apologist for him. Yeah. See
what he says. See exactly the words he
uses. This is no it's an open secret.
He's very nonchalant about it. Let's see
what he says.
Last year says the right belongs to the
Jewish people.
When we are Jews in the states, in
Australia, in England, in Jerusalem, we
are facing to one place
Sharif Mount Temple Mount
that I mean that's religion. Of course.
Talking about a religion when you're
talking about people and the land and
where they live, is it irrelevant?
Absolutely.
So, you can't really justify
ownership over religion when there are
so many different types of Arabs.
Of course not. But I'm just explaining
that what we are what the way that we
see Jerusalem, it's different way than
any other religion. As a Jew, you can
live everywhere in the world. You can be
the most Orthodox Jew. If you don't live
in Jerusalem, you cannot
uh keep the entire commitment of God.
Do you want to see a Sheh Jar
that is
Jewish?
Of course.
Without
Arabs.
I want to see Jews. Yes.
Yeah. You want to see Jews openly? You
are bloody Nazi, brother. This guy's a
Nazi. There's no difference between him
and them. What the What is the
difference? Tell me the material
difference between his his objective and
the Nazis objective. This is a classic
case of someone who's taking the
methodology and the ideology of the of
those who used to defeat them and beat
them and humiliate them.
What is the material difference between
you and the Nazis? You want to see the
whole area? is basically admitting to
ethnic cleansing and you're a deputy
mayor. This mayor king, his surname is
king, coming out and saying, "We want to
see a Jewish area.
Look what they do. Look what they're
doing. Coming into the house." Look how
they come into people's house. Look at
screaming. This is how they go into
people's house.
Most cowardly men in the world.
Look at this. They thought you wouldn't
be caught.
They thought you wouldn't be caught.
It's the age of social media. It's the
age of social media. Look at this. Don't
open the door.
Look at that. [music]
Look at this.
This is fantastic journalism, I have to
say. Brilliant journalism. Look at this.
They're going into a house.
It's our house.
This is because of Hamas. You liar. This
is because of Hamas.
Guys, honestly, you have to go and watch
this 20-minute segment on Vice. You have
to watch it. It is a mustwatch. You will
see the blatant, the flagrant, the open
arrogance,
the racism, the oppression.
These people are brimming with
oppression. They are brimming with
oppression. And then you have this
little pathetic cheerleader mascot
little boy, this academic unic, Ben
Shapiro,
trying to act as an apologist for the
for this. You are an academic unic and
you make me sick. How dare you?
How dare you justify this?
You think you have a case? Anybody who
looks at the events that are taking
place between the proverbial David and
Goliath, and believe me, you are not
David by any stretch of the imagination.
And if David was here, he would be WITH
US, NOT WITH YOU.
You are the Goliath.
But you know what?
I tell you something. You're waking up
the sleeping giant of Islam.
We are a sleeping giant. And the more
you show us this stuff, the more we
unite. And the more we put away our
differences and our squabbbling
problems that we have and the more we
know what the priorities are.
And the more the sleeping giant opens
one eye because the moment we sit up,
when the Muslim community, worldwide
community sits up or worse yet for you,
stands up,
it's going to be all over.